vous avez passé un bon été alors on
enchaîne avec ce kiosque de rentrée
consacré à la nouvelle saison de la
Maison de la poésie et pour nous la
présenter c'est tout de suite Jacques
Fournier son directeur
dites-moi dites-moi je suis fâché très
fâché d'apprendre que vous êtes encore
malade vous avez encore faire des excès
de nourriture au cours de vos mit dîner
avec ce M monde que je déteste qui vous
prend tout et qui ne vous rend rien les
nouveautés c'est un compagnonnage qu'on
a créé cette année avec le le comédien
Charles Gonzalez comédien metteur en
scène que l'on avait déjà accueilli les
années précédentes pour des spectacles
qu'il a créé ici ou qu'il a repris ici
et voilà je lui proposé de nous
accompagner tout tout au long de l'année
il a été reconnu comme étant un des
trois plus importants et plus forts
spectacles du Festival d'Avignon cette
année avec un gros succès
public voilà qu'il a porté pendant 3h3
sur scène c'était complètement
hallucinant il avait joué cette trilogie
ici je l'ai proposer de nous accompagner
tout au long de l'année d'être porteur
de de ses propres projets d'artistes de
comédiens de mur en scène à travers
certains spectacles qu'il va reprendre
tels que les les confessions de
Saint-Augustin ou qu'il va créer euh
principalement deux un autour de Antonin
Arau le 11 avril à partir de son propre
texte sur Antonin Arau et sur
l'évocation de des guerres on va dire le
24 janvier sur un texte de medite le dez
voilà et au-delà de ça Charles va va
animer un un atelier de création de mise
en voie de texte autour d'Antonin harau
et il va nous accompagner de du jour de
la du lancement de saison le le le 27
septembre puisqu'il sera présent pour ce
lancement de saison jusqu quasiment le
dernier jour puisque le le 30 mai on va
lui confier une carte blanche il dis il
quittera jamais
jamais non je soure
actementrible
deter les arch
AR de continuer correctement le travail
je sousigné docteur en médecine de la
Faculté de
Paris certifie que mademoiselle Camille
claud est atteinte de troubles
intellectuel très sérieux dans le cadre
de poésie Eveline donc ce ce festival
qu'on organise avec le conseil général
ça commencera le 26 26 septembre on sera
à saint-illier Laville dans l'église de
saint-illier la ville avec Lucienne
Deschamps et ses musiciens et on
terminera à le 5 octobre dans
l'après-midi avec Lucien Deschamps qui
reviendra mais cette fois-ci avec des
poètes et avec Olivier barbaran et tout
cela à la maison lesatriol Ragon à
saint-arnou
Jean-Marie Machado mais là c'est une
vieille vieille relation aussi il
accompagnera le le le Antonio placer
chanteur
poète galicien qui voilà que j'ai envie
de faire venir depuis très longtemps à
la Maison de la poésie et ils ont monté
à deux un projet incroyable qui
s'appelle réubli Alma dans lequel le ce
géant qui est Antonio placer chante et
dit des textes en français en galicien
en espagnol mais aussi dans sa propre
langue puisquil a inventé une langue il
le raconte quand il était enfant pour
voilà pour s'inventer des histoires et
il sera accompagné au piano seul par
Jean-Marie Machado ça ce sera en février
ser dans le cadre d'une grande soirée
consacrée à Antonio
placer
15 novembre c'est la
date retenue par le Le Pen Club et
amnistie internationale pour les
écrivains persécutés nous avons une
soirée qui s'appelle maintenant la
soirée des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés et empêchés ces écrivains
ils seront au nombre de qure ce seront
quatre écrivains syriens qui vivent en
France actuellement accompagné par un
musicien syrien pour une grande soirée
et tout au long de la semaine qui aura
précédé et ça c'est important aussi de
le préciser ces écrivains auront
rencontré des lycéens des collégiens des
étudiants pour parler de leur histoire
donc il y aura achar naout il y aura
maramal masserie Fada Souleiman et un
jeune écrivain aussi Omar
Souleiman l'aria calda I galleggianti
filavano in superficie una Grossa Luna
l'air
chaud la fourgonette qui amène le bois à
brûler R de la
ch ber c'est une musicienne
violencéliste de de belle qualité de de
formation classique qui enseigne à
Versailles et donc elle a depuis
quelques temps elle elle a découvert
cette d'accompagner le texte poétique
donc elle a monté un programme mensuel
donc un jeudi par mois beaucoup d'humour
mais des choses aussi très graves on
évoquera le 20 on évoquera la
quarantaine on évoquera les femmes et
voilà ça sera un programme très
éclectique sur ces ces six rendez-vous
dans l'année à partir du mois de janvier
jusqu'au mois de
juinêes
ma on aura quelques spectacles jeunes
public dans cette maison on travaille
avec on travaille encore cette année
avec les staminés
euh au mois de de mars on accueillera
aussi ici euh euh les barons perchés
c'est une proposition de la harpiste
Isabelle Olivier qui va créer une
version concertiste et et sonore à la
ferme de bbas en février autour d'une
sorte d'adaptation du Barron perché de
Italo Calvino et puis à la toute fin de
l'année on propose un compte qui
s'appelle turlu tutu qui a été écrit par
Hervé Toulet qui est un un qui a été
monté par une compagnie slovène euh avec
une comédienne française
et Juliette Morau et ce spectacle c'est
c'est c'est un spectacle très court qui
dure 35 minutes euh qui est un spectacle
d'objet de basé sur le mot sur le
son
ça
ça là-bas
h oh
il y aura encore comme d'habitude ENF ça
devient une habitude et j'en suis très
heureux des des moments d'atelier
d'écriture certains weekend ici donc
dans le programme tout est
indiqué c'est encore moi oui parce que
j'ai oublié de vous dire que la semaine
prochaine il y a une toute nouvelle
formule du kiosque comment oui là c'est
les sorties ciné au micro d'éod moine
c'est bien tu suis c'est bien c'est un
très beau film c'est très fin c'est très
subtile ouais c'est réussi et leilla
becti est dans un registre qu'on ne
connaissait pas jusqu'à présent ah comme
le premier c'est très con c'est c'est
très drôle c'est voilà c'est on veut
faire une suite mais on le dit bien que
on va essayer de faire mieux dans cette
suite et franchement c'est déjanté c'est
c'est drôle c'est inattendu donc je
trouve qu'il y a pas assz d'action ça
bouge pas assez mais moi j'ai pas
compris l'araignée donc je suis déçu je
filme j'ai pas compris l'histoire le
film en soit il est bien il est bien
réalisé les acteurs ils sont bons les
acteurs ils sont ils sont super bons
mais il manque quelque chose c'est très
bien joué les actrices sont
superbes mais ça finit ça finit comme un
peu en serpent de mer d'accord voilà
alors je dis que ça parce que faut pas
raconter l'histoire mais c'est c'est
très bien moi j'ai bien aimé bon c'est
pas rapide c'est un film L mais c'est
très bien joué c'est c'est prenant il y
a des beau Bell parties musical dans le
film et c'est un bon film il aborde en
fait tous les problèmes liés aux
hôpitaux et aux réduction de crédit et
puis ainsi que gérer la vie des médecins
ça alterne pas mal les
scènes tragiques et puis les scènes
comiques c'est ce qui est c'est ce qui
fait la vie des médecins oh patle tu
peux nous envoyer la chronique ciné là
cette semaine c'est g Pino attrape merci
bonjour c'est la rentrée des classes
alors pour que ce soit un moment sympa
pour tout le monde nous vous proposons
de passer un moment agréable au cinéma
Gren de Trapp ce sera ce vendredi 5
septembre à 20h45 il s'agit de
l'avant-première du film
solong plus jamais me souci je vais
finir le mois c'est ça que tu
veux mat
selon c'est le premier long métrage de
Bruno Mercier et c'est en recherchant
une musique pour son film qu'il a
rencontré Cohen et lui a demandé de
tenir le rôle principal Cohen c'est
avant tout un musicien et un compositeur
il fait partie du groupe horor chat et
c'est donc son tout premier rôle après
la projection il y aura un mini concert
acoustique il a composé la musique du
film et il viendra l'interpréter
quelques titres en acoustique avec sa
guitare au grenier
à
riche quand je
voudrais revanche
ça c dans LEM décv je actrice s'appelle
Juliette du qui est coméen
profnelleouve réuli les
planch le vendredi 5 septembre à 20h45
pensez à réserver sur notre site
www.cinemagrenieracel et encore une date
à retenir avant de nous quitter un grand
concert gratuit de Urban salsa avec le
groupe la33 la pour ceux qui a espagnol
c'est le 13 septembre à gui en cours au
gymnase des droits de l'homme à 21h et
c'est gratuit j'ai dit céta
gratuit